France is one step closer to a new
president protesters scuffle with police
overnight after the first round of the
presidential election more than two
dozen people were arrested for the first
time in France is modern history voters
turned away from mainstream candidates
and parties yesterday they chose
centrist and Manuel Macomb and populist
marine lepen for the second round
Elizabeth Palmer is in Paris Elizabeth
good morning good morning yes indeed the
French people voted for change in a big
way yesterday both candidates from the
right and the left now headed for the
runoff our Mavericks in their own ways
both of them bucking the very powerful
French establishment in first place
emmanuel macron he's a former investment
banker and economics Minister whose
agenda borrowed from the left and the
right without the backing of an official
party only in one year he told delighted
supporters we have changed the face of
French politics macro has never run for
office before but he is used to breaking
the mold at 16 he fell in love with his
high school drama teacher more than 20
years his senior and now 39 and 64 years
old they've been married for more than a
decade in second place the far right
candidate marine lepen who told cheering
crowds so as it was an historic result
llop ends populist promises will sound
familiar to americans shutting down
immigration anti-globalization
renegotiating trade agreements to
protect jobs at home she also wants to
follow weddings lead and take France out
of the European a crowded field of 11
candidates and ask
ridden campaign left voters like an
Sophie Perisher frustrated the campaign
was a with a mess I've never seen that
in France what was unusual about it
hardly talking about economics more
noises personal affairs and things like
that but today millions of French
citizens woke to find the traces of a
turbulent campaign being scrubbed away
and a clear choice facing them in two
weeks time that choice of course is
between a right wing president lepen and
a center-left president mackerel but
already analysts are saying mrs. lepen
doesn't have any chance of winning
especially as some of the other
candidates in the primaries have all
thrown their support behind mr. Mack
home specifically to block lepen Nora
that has settled world markets yeah
Justine young man isn't he my goodness I
didn't know that he is he his wife was
much older like 25 years old where I'm
thinking it really is age is just a
number right as well wow that's a very
interesting little nugget there yeah
thank you to lose a summer